this shiny metal is constantly in a
liquid state
[Music]
this is mercury
we normally see this metal in tiny
quantities but what would happen if we
took thousands of liters of it and
filled a pool entirely with liquid
mercury
[Music]
and then what if
you jumped into it
what would liquid mercury due to your
skin
[Music]
how would it affect your brain
[Music]
and
could you swim in it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you jumped into a pool full of
liquid mercury
mercury is more than 13 times denser
than water and substantially heavier
it's also much thicker with greater
surface tension than water as well
so what would it feel like if you jumped
into a pool of this liquid metal
[Music]
before we fill up our pool with liquid
mercury we're going to need to find a
lot of it
[Music]
mercury is a rare metal found in earth's
crust and due to it being so rare it's
also quite expensive
filling an entire pool full of liquid
mercury would cost hundreds of thousands
if not millions of dollars
once you've acquired all your liquid
mercury you can now fill up your pool
but
due to liquid mercury being so much
heavier than water
you'd need to make sure that your pool
is reinforced to handle such a heavy
weight
okay that was very time consuming and
expensive but
we finally have our pool full of liquid
mercury
and now it's time to jump in
and as soon as you jumped in you'd be
met with a thud rather than a satisfying
splash
due to the density of the liquid mercury
you wouldn't sink down into the pool
instead your feet would be submerged and
that's about it
if you were to dive head first into the
pool from a three meter ladder
then you'd probably get knocked out from
the impact of hitting the liquid mercury
but just because you don't get injured
from the jump itself that doesn't mean
you'd be safe
assuming you jumped into the pool with
standard swim attire you wouldn't be
wearing any shoes
this means at first your feet would be
making direct contact with the liquid
mercury
[Music]
this would cause severe burns and
irritation
and this would only worsen as you'd most
likely lose balance from just standing
on your feet
it would be like standing on watery
jello and would be incredibly difficult
to balance on
so you'd most likely fall on your back
or stomach
you still wouldn't sink in but now your
whole body would be covered with the
liquid mercury
[Music]
and the longer it stays on your skin the
worse it would get
prolonged exposure to liquid mercury
would lead to it getting absorbed by
your skin
and once that happens the mercury would
make its way to your organs including
your brain
and this is where mercury poisoning
would set in
and if you think you could avoid all
this by wearing a wetsuit and keep
mercury from touching your skin at all
think again
that's because just inhaling the liquid
mercury fumes would poison you sometimes
even faster than just touching it
the longer you stay in the pool the
worse it would get
you would start with a headache and
you'd start to feel woozy
at this point you should probably get
out of the pool
but even if you managed to survive this
long
this much exposure to liquid mercury
would stay with you for a long time
if not forever
over time the symptoms of mercury
poisoning would include speech
difficulties
lack of coordination and even vision
loss
and if you didn't manage to get out of
the pool
you'd pass out and die from the metals
fumes
[Music]
okay so jumping into a pool full of
liquid mercury is a terrible idea but
let me tell you
it wouldn't be the worst liquid to swim
in
have you ever heard of medusa
the snake-haired greek monster who turns
people to stone with a single glance
well she may just be a myth but there is
an area so deadly that it could actually
turn you to stone
the infamous lake natron
what makes lake natron's water so
dangerous
what kind of creatures live there
and could you survive if you fell in
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you jumped into lake natron
before we take the plunge we'd better
look at what lake natron is made of
much like the dead sea this tanzanian
lake doesn't run off into any oceans or
rivers
this allows it to soak up all that salty
desert rain
[Music]
soupy
yet what makes it especially lethal is
its close proximity to the active
volcano oldonio lengai
the volcano spews a rare kind of lava
rich in sodium and potassium carbonate
called natural carbonate or natron for
short
releasing into the water this mix of
sodium carbonate and sodium bicarbonate
were key ingredients once used in
egyptian mummification
creating the perfect preservative in
lake form
the whole chemical composition is
extremely alkaline with ph levels of
10.5 close to that of ammonia
this gives the lake its rosy hue
any birds who happen to take a dive and
don't make it out become calcified in a
hardened stone-like husk
talk about killing two birds with one
stone
in 2013 wildlife photographer nick
brandt was one of the first to document
this phenomenon
he discovered several stone birds and
other unlucky animals in the dry season
when the water had receded
he theorized that since the lake is so
mirror-like and reflective
the birds must have flown right into it
as if it was a big glass door
but despite so many birds dying in lake
natron there is a particular species
flourishing
turns out the lake's toxic waters
provide a safe haven from predators
making it perfect flamingo flocking
grounds
so if flamingos can handle it
couldn't we
well it's not that simple unfortunately
flamingos thrive in salty lakes because
of their tough skin and scaly legs which
prevent burns
they can drink the fresh water from
nearby springs or geysers at the edges
of the lake and if they're desperate
enough they can even filter salt water
with special glands in their nasal
cavities
and to top it all off their strong
stomachs allow them to feed on the toxic
algae found throughout the lake
this makes lake natron the perfect spot
to raise and protect their young
[Music]
so let's say we tried to live like a
flamingo and decided to take a dip
well depending on the time of year the
water can be up to 60 degrees which is
hot enough to cause third degree burns
in five seconds or less
also i wouldn't plan on doing any fancy
dives or cannonballs as its shallowness
is also chock-full of sharp salty
structures
you wouldn't be turned to stone
instantly but if you happen to drown and
stay submerged your entire body would
harden and be preserved
if people found you hundreds of years
later you might still have your hair and
organs intact
yeah still looking spiffy after all
those years
like mummification natron's super high
alkalinity stops the decomposition
process
thankfully this means you'd be safe from
vultures or any other hungry scavengers
looking for a snack
if you waded into the lake at a time
when the water temperature was lower
it could feel more like a hot tub
but your eyes or any open wounds would
sting like crazy because of all that
salt
i'd strap on some goggles if i were you
in 2007 another bird flew straight into
this chemical cocktail
a group of wildlife videographers
plunged into lake natron's toxicity when
their helicopter crashed
the pilot suffered a broken leg and
another passenger had a broken hip
incredibly one of the passengers managed
to struggle ashore and alerted some of
the maasai tribes people nearby
they quickly built stretchers and
carried the injured to land in the nick
of time
even though you could survive lake
natron's waters
i'd stick to a swimming pool if i were
you
you could try a swimming pool of
something more exotic
like your stomach acid
it's as strong as battery acid and it
can melt steel
your stomach acid lives inside of you
and helps digest your food
is stomach acid dangerous
if it's this powerful
why doesn't it hurt us
and what would happen if we jumped into
a pool full of the stuff
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we jumped into a pool full of
stomach acid
that's right stomach acid is compared to
battery acid in terms of the damage it
can do it can range from a 1 to a 3 on
the ph scale meaning it's extremely
acidic
that's because stomach acids main
component is hydrochloric acid which is
a highly corrosive substance
the reason it can live inside us is due
to a special mucous membrane that lines
our stomachs
but what would happen if we covered all
our skin with it
now before we jump into a pool full of
stomach acid first thing we need to do
is figure out how we're going to be able
to fill up an entire pool with stomach
acid
let's assume that we're swimming in an
average six by six meter pool that can
hold 55 000 liters of liquid
a stomach can produce at most one and a
half liters of stomach acid a day so
to fill up an entire pool we'd need the
stomachs of over 50 000 people
okay so we found 50 000 volunteers who
were able to help us fill up the pool
before you even jump into it you're
going to notice the awful smell
whenever there's excess acid in your
digestive tract it can cause your breath
to stink so multiply that by 50 000
and you'd get an idea of how awful the
pool would smell
you'd be surrounded by horrible bad
breath odor
and that's even before you jump in
as soon as you take the plunge
you'll feel stinging in your eyes and
your nostrils
to get a sense of what this might feel
like
have you ever had lemon juice squirted
in your eye
it would be similar to that as lemon
juice and stomach acid have a similar ph
level
but if you remember to bring your
goggles and your nose plugs hopefully
you'll be able to avoid this part
what's much less avoidable is the
stomach acid making contact with your
skin
when it does it'll cause some mild
irritation right away
luckily the epidermis layer of your skin
should be able to protect you before it
starts to hurt too badly
if you jump into the pool and hop right
back out even with your skin all covered
in stomach acid you'd be relatively okay
apart from the mild irritation
as long as you wash the acid off with
soap and water and towel off you'll be
totally fine
but
what if you stayed in the stomach acid
for much longer
if you didn't get out right away the
acid would slowly eat your
skin this would eventually leave you
covered in second and third degree burns
if you didn't manage to cover your eyes
during the swim you'd slowly lose your
vision and end up blind
and your nose it would dissolve from the
inside if the acid touched it long
enough
oh and if you accidentally swallow some
of it you'll inevitably vomit it back up
ugh what'd you have for lunch
so given the dangers here it's probably
best you don't try it you'd be best to
leave stomach acid where it belongs and
that's inside of us digesting our food
but what if we went inside a stomach
more specifically a whale's stomach
[Music]
well that's a story for another
what if